welcome and thanks for taking out the
time for yourself for what will
hopefully be a nice inward journey so
just start off sitting upright feet
planted on the ground if your ideally on
some type of a firm chair and start to
soften your gaze if your eyes are still
open
gently close them I like to leave my
hands on my lap palms up to the sky
but whatever feels comfortable for you
and then with your eyes closed
gently become a little bit more aware of
your breaths make them a little bit
deeper and a little bit slower at your
own time and breathe in breathe out just
a little bit deeper and a little bit
slower so the whole idea behind
meditation is trying to ease all the
chatter that exists in our brains trying
to still our thoughts and so as we do
that and every meditation I'm going to
try to introduce some frameworks ways of
thinking about your mind but as you try
to quiet the mind it will inevitably get
distracted it might get distracted by
some noise in the room or some noise
outside or more likely it'll get
distracted by thoughts that are just
surfacing into your consciousness and if
that happens don't let it make you
anxious a lot of folks when they
meditate they worry that they're doing
it wrong and then if they get distracted
it actually makes things worse they say
I'm never going to be able to do this
meditation thing the important thing is
to approach the meditation with the
spirit of fun the spirit of curiosity
have a sense of humor about it we are
all literally human and we do very human
things and so when you find your mind
wandering a bit just laugh it off and
say oh there you go mind just
come back to the stillness not a big
deal don't beat up on yourself over it
and as part of that as we go through
this meditation as much as possible try
to keep a little bit of a smile on your
face your eyes are closed but you can
still smile a little bit or at least
smile with your mind reminds you that
this should be fun
this is relaxing so with that said let's
keep breathing in breathing out a little
bit deeper a little bit slower and the
framework that I'm going to introduce
for how you can steal your mind is one
that I use a lot which is imagining all
the thoughts in your subconscious as the
ocean and the surface of the ocean is
the interface between your subconscious
and your consciousness and most of us
have a pretty choppy surface there's a
lot of thoughts that are jumping up and
down out of our subconscious and
sometimes we're drowning in those
thoughts and one way to think about it
is we can elevate ourselves we can
elevate ourselves above the surface of
that water and when you start to elevate
yourself you're not suppressing the
thoughts but you're just looking down on
them you see that they're still there
the surface is still choppy there's
still waves but as you rise and you look
down on it you realize that you are not
those thoughts you are not the surface
of the water so whether the thing that's
bothering you is an assignment you have
to do or some interpersonal relations or
just something in your life not working
out the way that you would like it to
remind yourself that that is not you you
are not defined by the outcome of that
situation those are just waves on that
ocean and the more that you surface
above them and you look at them and and
analyze them you realize that they have
no control over you and once that
happens thing
start to slow down the surface of that
water begins to get calmer and calmer
and calmer and there you are floating
above that surface just pure awareness
and you realize that you're a lot more
than you thought you were you aren't
just your physical body you aren't just
those thoughts that you see as waves on
the surface of that ocean you aren't
even just that identity that you
associate yourself with your name your
position in the world your status what
people think of you your relations those
are aspects of you but they aren't you
you are something much bigger than all
of them
you are the space in which they occur in
which they happen but they aren't you
and now let's just try to sit in that
pure awareness for the next minute or so
and once again if your thoughts wander
not a big deal that's just the
choppiness on the surface of that water
and you need to elevate yourself back to
that pure awareness and if the quiet
bothers you don't worry I will be back
in about a minute
all right so that was a relatively short
amount of time for you to be on your own
and as you'll see as we do more and more
advanced meditations give yourself more
and more time and over time you won't
need me talking in fact that will
probably annoy you you'll just be able
to sit down and still your mind and
realize that you are not your thoughts
and there's these things that are
bothering you they're only going to
bother you as much as you let them
bother you and the whole scheme of
things in all of time and space none of
them are really what should define you
or are anywhere near as important as we
sometimes make them out to be I'll see
you in the next meditation